non so voi ma io stesso rimasto quindi
sarò rapido veloce
facciamo un salto in avanti
finestra a finestra su uno spazio di
nuovo
iniziamo dalle postazioni tempo li
stiamo da tempo
20 aprile
unicamente un luogo come un luogo
paesino della bassa bergamasca
abitanti
4.364 i 20.000 20 in rapida discesa
provate a pero a quella sinistra con
questa fede fuori dalla finestra ring
aprile 2020 attivo il nuovo
dovete assolutamente niente non ci sono
tensioni ci sono negozi sono automobili
non ci sono animali
sei solo era quanto di più simile a un
apocalisse nucleare
io avessi pensato
cosa fai
guardando dalla finestra
vive fuori c'è lambo calisse
cosa fai leggi virgin o non aiutato da
fare leggi benji scrivi crea guarda
serie televisive guai al cinema
impegnati a 5 no però a casa del
presidente fai cose prova prova no
io non so voi cosa avete fatto l'anno
dopo con giusy caso meglio del tappino
2020 stavo
savona però che sui soffitti
mi chiedevo quando
sarei
quello non le mani mercoledì giovedì
venerdì sabato e domenica questi nomi
stesso non ce l'avevo q6 casa col
bambino sei a casa con la moglie non
etica e allora
tempo è questo il tempo dell'apocalisse
non passato
ciao
guardare fuori dalla finestra
la cosa sono imposto di fare
scrivere quel dialogo che io ogni giorno
scrivo accompagnato il mio maggiordomo e
pubblicare sui social come avevo sempre
fattore di
mattina
si può
salisse se dentro c'è un apocalisse si
scrivo di me siete anni sta capendo
dall'altra parte dell'italia chi è nino
vicino di casa
facciamo un po di lato non
abbiamo un altro sia
germania
1801 un signore può arcigno fratelli
molti progressi
compositore l'udine van beethoven decide
di dar all'unità
un'opera la sonata al chiaro di luna tu
oggi in ascolti è
l'ora
vecchio da
corso di oltre
al trofeo si sa
non siamo più in germania siamo in
francia un signore con questo mondo con
vari sento occhialini tondi baffi bojan
e li fanno tutti parte puliani questi
compositori il nome claude chi si
chiama di lui e
lo
scemo non ce l'aveva la novità tra loro
chiese che riesce a comporre questa
musica che io lo ascolto adesso deve
ancora via ma chi è il mio vicino di
casa non è un signore
1895 e un altro 1801 un tedesco un
francese e allora allora si pensa perciò
quando noi ci emozioniamo leggendo
guardando osservando
noi bianchi me pian già
fatto ieri ecco
casa che ciò non sta guardando dalla
finestra in cui noi tutti i giorni
guardiamo
sta raccontando qualcosa a una parte noi
che è così tanto radicata che parla a
tutti
qual è il segreto
su questi giorni sul concetto concetto
di profondità e come se il fondo simoni
scrivi pudico e uno dice profondità i
quesiti affetti vendicare
dalla festa allo stomaco e risalire la
profondità è qualcosa di estremamente
razionale poi a scavare nel profondo
dell'umanità tira fuori le grandi verità
così la profondità
questo
scavare nel buio
nell'umido come sul fondo di un pozzo
profondo
quali sono le dimensioni di una stanza
ci
larghezza e
non significa andare giù
bidimensionalmente con un pozzo
artesiano dei cosiddetti fondi andare
quindi quando si approfondì voi fan
rovina
sono qui tenere più persone
possono
comprendere più peso provato a dire a
una persona ti capisco la reazione qual
è il
tuno mitici davvero è un mai aspettata
da anni studiano ci sentiamo 11 nella
nostra realtà ma prova di ri su un
trenino
sapendo che quello che stai dicendo che
lui
tendoni
lui e parte di te che tu sei lui questo
cos'è
la minuto un antidoto una parola ci
siamo sentiti ripetere un ricettario di
volte tale per cui ha perso qualunque
tipo di significato e qualunque tipo di
accezione negativa cosa farò letto
larizzazione
ma di un argomento crea una squadra
destra e sinistra
prendi l'altro argomento le squadre
scambiano e tu mi mandavi al campetto
che facevi circa un apporto singola poi
a un certo punto si cambiano alle spalle
si
candida argomento si dividono di nuovo
ancora cambia argomento ancora ma la
domanda è chi angel vince e
c'è chi riesce a fare gol che ci ha
organizzato il torneo
perché questa la domanda che ci facciamo
chi è che davvero ha ottenuto quello che
vuole polarizzando e cioè trasformandoci
tutti in piccoli atomi piantati come
vecchioni
sul terreno
chi è che ti farà domanda
oppure ti sei dato dalla scozia
una via
e paola nardini
comprensione parte da quello
dall'empatia dai dire che io te un'altra
persona dall'altra parte dell'italia
un'altra persona dall'altra parte del
mondo in un altro tempo
provato quello che provo io ho trovato
quello che io sono empatia siamo tutti
la stessa persona soffriamo tutti alla
stessa maniera e non esiste la montagna
dei problemi su cui ci sentiamo soli
se una tela montuosa ed è un capello
unisse pone persona questa stanza di
questo paese probabilmente anche in
questo mondo della catena ci permette di
essere detenuti giuliante altro non è in
grado di non essere mai spezzata una
catena intrisa di una magia quella magia
che abbiamo parlato essere l'empatia ora
prendete la pro la polarizzazione
praticamente la parola il presidente
fide e
impera dividi e comanda espressione non
abbiamo rimandato indietro ai romani ma
no è una cosa dei francesi che volevano
dargli un certo tipo di spessore
nella ma francese forte conta l'empatia
di questi e tutte capaci poi aprite la
finestra
base fuori questa pallina di concedi
chiudete la finestra aria
come per noi siamo poi
andiamo